how are you guys already made it to
dessert good for you you are you allowed
to eat or what are you on punishment did
you get in trouble earlier she got the
entire dessert and you're not allowed to
touch it I noticed I know when a
girlfriend is mad because she'll put it
in the centers you're like babe help
yourself this time she's like I'm
[__] it's one spoon what did you do
that's the problem you don't even know
dumbass
dude you guys are [__] doing it I'm
proud of you they have dessert and now
they're getting tater tots and french
fries I [__] love everything I see
right here that's real love yeah look at
that I can tell that's real low because
they're eating like they're never gonna
cheat on each other if she was eating
like that and he was getting a salad I'd
be like he's [__] somebody else
tomorrow